foreign
[Music]
just shy of Seven Grand a month but I
would have had more I had to give some
back during the pandemic right okay
about three all together and you bought
a house would you all now refinancing I
bought a house from saving my money
working hard save my money bought a
house which used to belong to you
correct we have to we we can't which you
didn't even know at the time I didn't
know but when I put I was sent like a
secret list of
sale and I was asked to find buyers
because they do that as well a bit of
that as well and I just honed you know
one property and when I did my you know
my super sleuth investigations I
realized that it was yours yeah and I'd
actually so I wasn't buying it blind
blind because actually you know if it's
good enough for me exactly
although I was selling it but I was
selling it you were selling it and I was
like why is he selling it but I did I
was satisfied and I did my DD I'd
actually and then I'd seen you when you
found it yeah and you did the YouTube
because I was following you on YouTube
yeah and you did the YouTube thing and
I'm like Oh my goodness
this is the sign I've seen the inside of
this property already yeah I don't need
to worry about doing a viewing I knew
what it was like so I just went ahead
and I just bought it I was three grand
short
and I had to borrow three grams and that
scriptures I gave jewelry yeah
money and then I paid everyone back and
then I refinanced it yeah and I'm at
this stage now looking for the next did
you pull out all your money all but
about seven Grand okay so you ended up
with a house for Seven Grand I'll tell
you what I sold that house because I
sold quite a lot of houses when we went
there's a bit of a misconception
sometimes people think that
um my training business is is like
really profitable to make loads of money
and don't get me wrong some months it
can be but more years than not my
training business has actually lost
money and my property business is what's
always kept it going so when we're into
lockdown and I have half a million
pounds a month
on venues and offices and staff
overheads right oh wow you know and and
and my property business a lot of the
training companies went bust over
lockdown my training company was
flourishing over lockdown because the
property business was able to continue
sort of you know financing the staff and
everything like that yeah and that's why
I sold some of my little houses just to
literally pay people's wages yeah and
you snapped it up I did I was annoyed
about that
that was one of my babies
I started about seven I still got hurt
at least he went into good person's
hands you know
I'm taking care of her and I've got
plans I've got big plans good yeah yeah
HMO
nature of course of course so rent when
did you when did you first discover
winter rents
do you know it's a funny story because I
was doing with rent I had
about nearly 20 years ago and I just
realized if I just rent out each room
I'm gonna make way more money but he
wasn't called rent to rent and that's
what I was doing so anyway fast forward
20 years later unemployed job Seekers
allowance blah blah you know failed
businesses behind me somebody said you
know this thing called rent to rent I
think you're really be good at that you
really like it and then I realized it
was what I did on that first Putney
property which I had to sell
um and so so I started a rental I had a
failed cleaning business I had a failed
restaurant
I I was fired from my letting agent job
I was listening's manager for a big
that's where I got a lot of my
background training yeah um but I was
letting this manager and I got fired
from there what are the fire
they just couldn't handle them couldn't
handle the great deal yeah yeah you know
if you're an entrepreneur though
sometimes sometimes if you're an
entrepreneur and you're in a job it's
not a good fit is it when you're working
with somebody yeah exactly all lasted
all after three months I think yeah
as a combination of I Can Feel It Coming
yeah and I just wanted to get out as
fast
me well right I used to sit at my desk
and go can I see this woman swan in and
go I want to see this for my client and
I want to see that for my client and
then jump in a Range Rover and zoom
hello
here I wanna I Wanna Live like that yeah
and now you do and I'm like rocking up
in your fancy new Mercedes with the top
off yeah you know living the good you
just moved housing too where do you live
now sorry oh sorry I didn't know it was
that kind of area it's beautiful it's
really lovely and where did you move
from I moved from streatham what made
you what made you move to Surah well my
kids have grown up the last one left
home is 19 and you know and um I had to
downsize so I just got an apartment
there yeah and um yeah and that's why I
moved that's why I moved but I used to
sit at my desk when I was working for
this estate agent and got how do I get
from here to there where I see that
woman Waltzing in and out and yeah
that's what I get from here to there
always pull my hair out and it is that's
a good that's good though because when
people don't think like that most people
will see somebody you know I was an
estate agent and I saw all these people
making all this money and most people
just think oh well that's their life
this is my life but but me and you were
the same because we're thinking how can
I do that yeah
like that yeah not hating no no no not
be grudging or on any Genesis
when you see someone super successful
though in property or any business you
can either
find an excuse oh they're only
successful because they're parents or
and you can hate or you can be inspired
so actually how can I how can I be more
successful yeah so okay so previously
you'd rented a property not rent to rent
but multi-rooms yeah which you owned
that's right yeah so you kind of knew
that you organically fell into the
strategy of multi-room renting and it's
like obvious right why would I rent a
property out to a family but I've been
room by room yeah so then when when did
you get your first rent to rent where
you're controlling your property I set
up the business five and a half years
ago I teamed up with a with a JV partner
and within about that was just for the
first one because I haven't done it for
so long yeah I was unemployed and you
know I was a single mom and uh I was
just a bit nervous you know
admin fee yeah yeah and I was just oh my
gosh so anyway I got that one that was
within the first
say three months of setting up the
business
um and uh got that through an agent and
it was my JV partner that had been a bit
had a bit more
um sort of experience in the rent to
rent Arena as it were so he walked me
through that one did the introduction
with the estate agent
um and because as well I didn't have
references they charged me a bit more on
the deposit sure side but you know it's
always around it though again a lot of
people a lot of people would say oh
they're saying that I haven't got good
references therefore I can't do it but
actually you say more how can I okay I
can pay a little bit more deposit right
and then I'd sort of piggy banks with
this guy right as well who had you know
how bad was your references at that
point did you have bad credit no
um maybe I did have bad credit back then
yeah yeah the credits are right now yeah
you know but um back then yeah and where
did that eight grand come from
um the eight grand was mainly savings
but um I've got to give credit my little
my little grandmother left this little
house in Jamaica wow riddled with
termites you know and my whole family
was saying to me yeah it's not worth
anything just leave it and for seven
years I pursued the the whole paperwork
of this company to get the probate and
then to do the sale and I just stuck
with it and I even had to fly to Jamaica
and eventually that's where I got the
bark of my money from nice and but as it
was going down I was just like I need a
parachute I've got to do something yeah
and that was when I got my first rent to
rent and I haven't looked back what was
what was it that how did you justify
because I know you spent thousands of
pounds coming on our training how did
you justify that decision because it's a
big step
um because first of all I followed you
on YouTube and everything you say I just
liked your energy the positive mindset
and you're just doing it and from the
age of 17 you were thinking that way you
know and all of those hurdles that you
overcame when people shut the door on
you and didn't no one believed in you
kind of thing apart from your family and
I just it just resonated with me and
then you know that's why I was able to
buy that property pretty much blind just
because you said so because you bought
it and it's good enough for you it's
good enough for me and I just yeah and I
just thought you know what more could I
learn let me expand my learning because
I have to say even with rent to rent you
need knowledge you cannot just rock up
and say well I've got some money I found
some property to rent I you need because
there are so many moving parts so many
things that can go wrong I'm not just
saying that I fight fires are fought so
many fires in my business I've got 45
units as I'm managing about 50 people
yeah and like even just on the way here
a boiler was down and a toilet seat was
loose and you know they're getting like
antsy about the toilet seat and uh but
anyway you don't know how to deal with
every objection every issue not just
from the from the tenants but from the
landlords the agents everybody yeah and
and you know you do build up the
confidence but you've got to have the
knowledge and you've got to stay on your
toes and you've got to keep up with the
knowledge what's happening with section
21 yeah right they're abolishing it
completely and you know what does that
mean how will that impact things and
that's why you keep you need to keep
your network going keep building up the
network and that was one of the big
benefits I mean the you know the
presenters were amazing
um very inspirational
you know I don't need motivation but I
love getting it anyway yeah yeah I think
it's motivating when you see people
making money and you when you when you
have knowledge and you're oh my gosh I
can do that exactly that's inspiring
exactly that's what it is and it's that
knowledge because I know I'm not just
going to sit within rent to rent either
I will be moving into developments yeah
um I've already done my first BR even
though I skipped me B the B bit or the r
bit
I didn't need the refund
s but I'm going to come back to that I'm
going to circle back to that and you in
your network and that's why going to
these courses because you're with people
on the same level of mindset where
they're prepared to invest in themselves
and one of the best investments you can
make is in yourself yeah that's the
first place yeah yeah it starts and talk
to me then about your rent to rent so
are they all went to hmos or are they
served accommodation they're all rents
Venture bars so they're all hmos what's
the air have you got one area would you
kind of South West London yeah that
ballpark it was a half hour drive from
my house and once I'm at one property is
no more than a 10 minute minute drive to
get to the next one and and how do you
find the landlords how do you present
rent to rent as an opportunity to the
language um you know what it has gotten
harder it has gotten harder but how I
did it was
um like I said I piggybacked with that
JD partner and he was the one that found
the first estate agent and that estate
agent then did
um introduce me to another property near
to the first one because that's their
badge yeah it just so happens and um so
when they introduced me to that one the
landlord fell out with the agent and
then the landlord came to me direct and
gave me two more properties he said you
keep this one and I'll give you two more
so those were three yeah so that's four
all in the bag and then the agent came
back to me and I took another two of
them but then I had to give them back
during lockdown but
um then one of my handyman a decorator
because I always tell my handyman look
out for a property for me I will pay you
you know I'll give you a referral fee so
one of my decorators handyman introduced
me to this landlady
and she's a doctor just very busy her
flat was run down it even smelled really
bad one of the rooms was disgusting like
a goat was living in there like this is
a house full of goats it really smelled
and uh yeah but I just had the vision
yeah I just had the vision and I said to
her don't worry and I put down a new
floor I did a little upgrade I got it
from a really good rug and no deposit I
don't know how I did that one I just
went for it it's like no deposit look at
the state of the place blah blah blah
and and that's been I've been dealing
with that for about three years that one
now I'm sure that will make that one
well do you know what it goes up and
down doesn't it and I haven't looked
lately but I average across the
portfolio they're about 650 to 700 per
property yeah and how do you know
whether a deal is good or not so when
you're taking a lot of rent around how
do you know if it's going to be a good
deal yeah you have to look at each room
see how much you can get for each room
and be moderate with that don't go for
the maximum because there's a range
often I can get six six fifty for this
room I can get seven seven fifty for
this room 725 if it's a couple 800 but
always I always go for the lower yeah um
estimate of what I can get add those up
um and then you're gonna take away you
know what you think is going to be the
expenses on top of the rent the minus
the rent minus your expenses which are
going to go up yeah and which is a bit
scary but you minus the expenses because
we provide cleaners every two weeks as
well
um and uh and what's left is your that's
your margin and you have to decide what
is the minimum so tell me Marcia what
are the benefits to the landlord I've
accepted why would the landlord not just
rent it out himself room by room oh no
no no no no most landlords they're
working or they're retired or they want
to retire they want to spend time with
their grandchildren their family their
loved ones or they're working and
they're really busy
um in demanding jobs you know and they
just you know they can sort of it just
can be a bit too much so the benefit is
first of all what I love to let them
know is it's a free service free to land
boards unlike an estate agent where
they're going to charge you a fee and
when the property is empty with an
estate agent you've still got to pay
your mortgage you're still shelling out
if you're a landlord so the benefits are
we look after the property we do regular
um Regular inspections you'll you know
how much is coming in every month
regardless it is empty or occupied it's
none of your business nothing to do with
you
um and uh you know we reference the
tenants we make sure they're keeping it
up we have all the hassle of of
marketing viewings getting them in
contracts and all of the compliance
stuff as well
um and hassle-free yeah just just look
at your bank account and say yeah
Marcy's paid me again yeah that's the
thing though because because the product
to the service that we're offering
landlords is a good service a lot of
people trying to get a rent to rent and
they're like I'm struggling to get
everything I think it's because they're
not sold themselves on how good the
service is that they're offering if
you're not sold yourself how can you
sell that landlord
well look we've got the business account
the client account you know we've got
all of the you know with the PRS
obviously you know we've got our
Indemnity insurance you know all of
those things so if anybody was to look
us up and do that kind of background
check they'll find all of that you know
with the DPS or no we change from them
to another one
um
and uh yes you have to know and I mean
and then you know I've got a great
website
um as well it's better than what it was
anyway what's it called it's called
umreallifestyle.co.uk real lifestyle
real lifestyle real yeah lifestyle yeah
what do you think what do you think
about energy prices rising so highly I'm
I'm mortified I'm horrified
um I'm speaking to the energy providers
at the moment uh to see you know what we
can do to get them down there's one
property in particular like I've got
gray hairs overnight when I saw the bill
yeah but um yeah the other thing that I
will be doing I think we should do is to
communicate with the houses and make
sure that they're aware of the pressure
um of those going up and what they can
do to minimize those costs as well yeah
sure
um
well well don't don't you know plug your
appliances out I've heard that somebody
may have a fan heater you know no no fan
heaters I mean obviously not now we
don't need that
um don't you know turn off the uh the
heating obviously when it's not needed
don't leave the water well water is not
really an issue is it but you know don't
leave water running and yeah do not be
mindful it's my attitude of the bill
prices is with a HMO what they're
renting is they're renting the room with
the bells included if the bills go up
then they're rent stuff yeah and I don't
think anyone's going to be able to get a
problem with that yeah that's it they're
paying for the bills to be paid yeah
exactly
what's more room rents go up a lot as
well I have put some up
um even before they said because it was
post-pandemic I put a lot of the rents
up because of you know to get rid of
them I had to rent them at really rock
bottom prices yeah so I've put some of
the rents up uh aiming to get them all
back to pre-pandemic prices levels and
uh and yeah definitely mulling over that
whole how am I going to break it to them
that you know your rent's probably add
20 quids or you know per month I think
they'll accept that I've got a that
that's where I'm going what do you think
um about occupancy is like what's
happening in the market generally with
your properties how what what kind of
occupancy rates do you have I'm 99 right
really yeah 45 units I've got maybe one
empty room at the moment yeah
how do you keep it so so full what are
some of the proactive things you have to
do to keep the houses for well we take a
two months notice so we've got a lot of
time to organize ourselves we've taken
good pictures from the job up on the
majority of the rooms yeah so they're
always ready to go picture perfect
um
rooms so that's another thing
um and uh so you're ahead of the game
and that's it and just get them out
there yeah on on um you know on the
usual yeah and if you've got two months
notice it is you've got two months to
find a new town quite possible isn't it
it's quite possible so you've got plenty
of time I mean we ideally I'm not going
to start viewings
um with two months but you know you've
got six to eight weeks to get that done
and it's plenty of time
um and uh and just yeah just do viewings
viewings respond quickly to inquiries
like I've got one person
that he his job is to he's just on the
spare room that's him yeah marketing
when a room comes up he knows where to
find the pictures he puts them out you
know and then he rejects and I say that
how much you in that room for now put
the price up for me does it straight
away and then you react you respond to
inquiries quickly it was interesting
for a while now and you've got a
portfolio you're making Seven Grand a
month all's good now when it comes to
you wanting to buy a property which you
have done you just bought one last year
if you're wanting to run it as a HTML
you've got the experience yeah because
ready to retina home is it good for
giving you cash loaders yeah so it's
almost like a training ground for how to
run successful properties it is it is
and um I'm going to uh yeah I think I
mentioned I'm going to actually convert
the one that I bought to a to an HMO and
that will pretty much double the income
yeah and I'm thinking of buying another
one nearby and I've already got the
management team in place to to handle
that as well to handle the whole the
whole thing because it's fun oh
um well
things like what what keeps me up like
when a room is just empty and it's
pandemic okay that that's then that's
then is that is oh man I'm telling you
it was hard it was hard man but no it's
like if I've got more than like if I've
got three rooms empty you know I don't
like any rooms empty that just keeps me
up that's like I've got a room
you ain't gonna pay the landlord I've
got it so so so do you think that rental
is super risky then because if you're
offering to guarantee that you're going
to pay the landlord and then if you
can't win the room's like you can't stop
it on you there is there is an element
of risk you know there is an element of
risk
um but you know that he who dares wins
you know or she who dares wins you you
it comes with the the territory if I
didn't do it and take that risk I
wouldn't have been able to buy that
property yeah I wouldn't be looking for
my second property now yeah and also I
wouldn't be able to be looking for land
in Gambia right now okay where I'm going
to build my my dream home wow that's the
plan I just got back from Gambia the
other day yeah you know you're driving
your nice new Mac what oh and I'm going
to be able to buy my I bought my dream
car
um a Mercedes drop top AMG line nice do
you know what though it kind of makes
you think when people say to me right
joint's really risky because I might be
able to turn the rooms out of course
there's risk right it's risk but my
thinking is if you're so scared that you
can't rent the rooms out
number one you've got to do diligence
before you take a property on anyway so
you've got to get knowledge number two
well what happens you'll never buy a
house then because if you buy a house
the same risk is there the only
difference is you know where you renting
you're having to sit your massive
deposit into it but if you're so scared
that you know what happens if it doesn't
work why is it doesn't you may as well
just stay at home and have a job yes
because you've got to take taxes
educated risk but you've got to take
risk to be an entrepreneur and it's not
for everybody rent to rent because this
is not for everybody you know what
happens is you start to earn you know
for most sort of let's say regular
people whatever that is but you know you
start to earn that whereas maybe you
were earning two grand a month before
you know maybe two and a half Grand
obviously people earn a lot more but if
you are in that bracket 1200 some people
are earning less
um and then before you know it you're
only three grand four grand a month five
grand a month you can save you can save
for those hard times when you need to
dip into your own pocket and pay people
who are working for you I've got to pay
that guy to do my marketing I'm taking
on another assistant who's gonna I'm
training her up to be the property
manager she can't wait and then we're
going to expand into talking about
what's next I'm expanding into a
maintenance company nice and that's
going to be another
um Revenue stream it's interesting that
you were fired as a land manager and now
you're hiring letters managers that's
right exactly and that's how you write
your own story you tell your own story
are you gonna is your story gonna be I
was so scared I didn't leave my job I
didn't take the risk I never got that
house I never was able to pay for
education for my children taking on
those holidays and like do you know what
I mean yeah take time off work during
the pandemic I was in Barbados for two
and a half months I don't want to sound
big-headed I'm not being beginning but
it actually happened because I had my
team here yeah and I was able to run
things remotely yeah and that's isn't
that part of the dream as well
absolutely you can't you can't have all
the other side you can zero over the
downside and of course it swings around
I think I can always find a reason why
to do something or a reason why not do
something yeah yeah it's about how bad
you want it listen my neck is on the
line and I'm so well aware so I I do
work hard I do work hard when I jump in
my car and when I'm walking to my car I
sometimes I just when I first got it
let's look at the window it just and it
makes me smile because I know how hard
I've worked I've worked so hard I fell
asleep in my car and the applicant was
saying are you Bossier are you gonna
show me this I was just zonked in the
middle of the day you know midnight up
making beds when one of the flats
flooded when we had those floods a few
months ago muggins not muggins but me I
was down on my hands and knees soaking
up mud yeah and dirty water you know
that flooded the flat because I wanted
it done as
I didn't have time to wait for anybody
yeah that was on my hands and knees
literally soaking up that nastiness yeah
and so you will put and don't think it's
a cushy number you will work hard and
yes there is there is risk but you just
gotta keep going and put the hours in
and save your money for those difficult
times when they come and then invest you
can keep investing in yourself so that
you're doing bigger deals so that you're
not just doing rent to rent you get to a
point and then there's a bigger picture
and the bigger picture
um could be and it is for a lot of
people going into developments why do
you why do you choose my training over
all the other property trainers
there was just something real about you
just real you know and because
I know what it's like to have to
overcome this and like a lot of people
do you know they have to overcome things
and I just resonated with your your
story you know and then I've got your
book buy low rent High yeah yeah yeah
you know and I read that in bourneville
yeah you bought a place exactly the
chocolate comes from yeah you know and I
just it was just very engaging and from
Humble background like myself yeah so
that's why it just resonated and you
just straight to the huh straight to the
jugular and I like that no messing about
yeah exactly why Gambia of Interest why
are you looking to build the well
um I was in Barbados and because I've
got a network in Barbados actually but I
realized the cost of living is quite
High there like the loaf of bread is
about Fiverr it's ridiculous
um and so as beautiful as it was I
started to hear about Gambia and people
saying to me Gambia this Gambia really
deals so I thought and then it was my
son my big son and his wife to be said
Gambia are you coming and I was like wow
so you're gonna buy a piece of lamb and
build your dreams yeah so no that's
where I'm gonna have it you can
um I found the land it's not it's a 20
minute walk from the beach beautiful and
I'm going to build a you know a house
with a pool right you know a dream a
dream house well what's your strongest
reason for doing this
do you know ah oh I had so many years of
going without
and I was a teenage mum I got pregnant
when I was I was 16 nearly 17. and one
of my raison detras was just I've got to
show everybody that's not the end of me
I am a winner I'm a winner I made a
mistake but I'm a winner and it's just
never gone away I just always want to
keep keep winning how do you feel now
achieving how does it feel now to to
achieve what you've achieved to be
making a very very good incoming
property to be managing 45 units buying
houses how does it feel to obtuse it
feels wonderful I'd be quite honest with
you it because I know that Blood Sweat
and Tears and the risk and you know that
I've put into it and and I know with the
failed businesses failed cleaning
company failed restaurant and other
business I started which I had to sit
down down because my babies were
arriving where you come from you know
and um and you know but now the youngest
is 19. so it's been and people were
calling me are you coming to this party
are you coming oh we're doing St Lucia
Jazz Festival this year are you coming
and I was always like no I can't yeah
now I've got to look after my precious
babies can anybody be successfully
profited
it's all about mindset yes
if you have the right mindset you
definitely it's like everybody can but
not everybody will
yeah exactly
um
that's that's it Young on the short
wherever you want to do if you want to
be successful in life
mindset
attitude positive like one of my strap
lines is your attitude is your out
dictates your altitude you know and
image imagination is everything it's a
preview of what is to come that I didn't
make these up
um that was Einstein and uh and um
sorry the name the Name Escapes me at
the moment but um yeah those sayings
um are are there and and I used to have
those type of slogans on my own when I
was living in my castle flat when I was
a single mom you know when I was 18 19
20 and I made my son read them we will
make a way either we will find a way or
we will make one that was that was one
of the slogans and and he remembers all
of that yeah and now he's doing so well
so well and it's about
if you don't have that mindset you can
get it yeah you can train your mind you
can retrain your mind don't let me start
talking about all of that
neuroplasticity and all of that stuff
um but you know you can train your brain
to think in a totally different way so
what would you say if someone was
watching this that maybe like yourself
came from very little humble beginnings
that really wants to get into property
what what are the what are the first
steps oh
um I would say first of all don't listen
to your friends don't share the good
news with anyone just do your own
research the information is out there
when I was coming up we didn't have the
internet you know we didn't have social
media Instagram and that's another
reason why I feel so good now because I
had to come over overcome so many odds
without having that kind of ability to
network and all of these you've got
access to gurus now gurus here talking
to you you know what I mean there's
nothing to stop you so I would and I'll
respond to everybody that messages me on
Instagram yeah every single message I
get yeah well I started messaging you
and you responded yeah that's the thing
it's like yeah the world now
everything's so exciting and accessible
so I say if you really want to be
successful at anything
um just believe it see it
believe it see yourself doing it train
yourself every morning that's what you
say that's what you say that's what you
see that's what you do I do it I still
do it every morning and write it down
Journal it write it down you know and
and take it out and look at it
um Bob Proctor yeah take it out I used
to have a business card which I wrote on
the back of the business card where I
had my job my last job where I was fired
from and on the back of it I wrote
something ridiculous like I will have a
hundred thousand pounds by 90 2018 and I
crossed it up it was 2016. cross it out
2018 crossed it out
but again and I have put it on my mirror
and um and it did happen yeah it did
when I did the refinance on that
property yeah you know yeah my ads your
house bang your house so I say and that
was from me coming from Hackney as a
single mum yeah bereaved from a teenager
because that father died and I raised
that son I didn't have a mum and dad
um you know it was
thing but I just kept on I just lived
for my son and I just kept believing
that I can be something great and then
I've read I've learned and so invest in
yourself believe in it and just keep
going for every single day keep going
for it amazing well I really appreciate
you coming and sharing the story thank
you I look forward to seeing you
continue to prosper yes I'll keep in
touch and big respect thank you very
much thank you well done
foreign
[Music]